FOX NEWS ALERT WELCOME BACK TO
CROSS COUNTRY MOSCOW, IDAHO
WHERE A DAY FILLED WITH
CELEBRATION WAS OVERSHADOWED BY
SADNESS.
THE UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO WINNER
GRADUATION INCLUDING TRIBUTE TO
THE FOUR STUDENTS MURDEREDs
NEARLY ONE MONTH AGO.
ONE OF THOSE VICTIMS KAYLEE
EXPECTED TO WALK ACROSS THE
STAGE AND GET HER DIPLOMA
INSTEAD POLICE PACKED UP HER
BELONGINGS AS HER FAMILY AWAITS
JUSTICE IN THIS CASE.
OUR FRIEND ALEX SIS LIVE IN
MOSCOW AS POLICE ISSUE A NEW
WARNING ALEXIS WHAT CAN YOU TELL
US?
>> LAWRENCE SINCE YOU WERE ON
THE GROUND JUST THE OTHER DAY WE
HAVE HAD NEW PIECES OF
INFORMATION LIKE INVESTIGATORS
LOOKING FOR A CAR BUT THIS
SHOULD BE A WEEKEND OF
CELEBRATION HERE YOU CAN SEE
BEHIND ME STREETS OF DOWNTOWN
MOSCOW NEAR THE UNIVERSITY ARE
EMPTY BECAUSE MOOD HERE IS
SOMBER, THOUGH, IT SHOULD BE
PRETTY MUCH CELEBRATORY THIS
WEEKEND BUT TONIGHT
INVESTIGATORS ARE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT PEOPLE
KNOW ABOUT THIS CASE.
AS THE KILLER IS NOT YET BEHIND
BARS THEY'RE TELLING PEOPLE TO
BE VIGILANT TAKE A LIVE LOOK AT
THE CRIME SCENE WE HAVE A CAMERA
RIGHT NOW AND GIVE YOU CLOSE
LOOK AT EXACTLY WHAT WE'VE SEEN
IN THE PAST 24 HOURS YOU CAN SEE
IT IS COVERED IN YELLOW TAPE
THERE AS POLICE INVESTIGATE THE
QUADRUPLE MURDER ROCKED THE
CAMPUS AND INNOCENT COLLEGE KIDS
STABBED TO DEATH NEARLY ONE
MONTH AGO AND STILL NO ARREST IN
THE CASE.
THE FAMILIES OF MADDIE KATIE AND
ETHAN LEFT WITH MORE QUESTIONS
THAN ANSWERS.
YOU CAN SEE IN THE DRONE VIDEO
JUST LAYOUT THE HOUSE WE KNOW
VICTIMS GOT BACK TO HOME AROUND
2:00 IN THE MORNING THAT --
DAY.
AND POLICE SAY THEY WERE KILLED
SOME TIME BETWEEN 3 AND 4 IN THE
MORNING.
WHAT HAPPENED INSIDE THE HOUSE
LAWRENCE STILL UNDER
INVESTIGATION.
THE POLICE CHIEF TELLS ME
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR A FIXED
BLADE KNIFE AND UNTIL THEY HAVE
AN ARREST, THEY'RE TALKING TO
EVERYONE.
>> JUST BECAUSE SOMEONE HAS BEEN
CLEARED RIGHT NOW DOES THAT MEAN
THEY MIGHT BE REINTERVIEWED?
MNCHTS, MANY HOURS HAVE GONE
INTO THAT AND SEVERAL
INVESTIGATORS AND TEAM HAVE
LOOKED AT INFORMATION THAT COMES
IN AND THEY'VE VERIFIED THAT
THOSE PEOPLE CAN BE CLEARED.
SO --
WHAT I WANT TO ASSURE THEM IS
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
AND WE'RE TAKING OUR TIME TO DO
IT RIGHT.
INVESTIGATORS BELIEVE THEIR ON
THE RIGHT TRACK LAWRENCE AND
MORE QUESTIONS THAN ANSWERS FOR
POOR KIDS FAMILIES AND POLICE
ARE LOOKING FOR A WHITE HYUNDAI
EXAMPLE THAT POLICE RELEASED
THEY BELIEVE IT IS A 2011 TO
2013 ELANTRA PARKED OR DRIVING
BY HOME AROUND TIME OF THE
MURDERS THEY BELIEVE THE PERSON
OR PEOPLE IN THAT CAR HAVE VITAL
INFORMS IN THE CASE THIS ALL
COMES AS WE MENTION THE POLICE
ARE NOW PUTTING OUT INFORMATION
THAT IF YOU'RE NEAR THE CAMPUS
OR IN MOSCOW, IDAHO YOU SHOULD
BE TRAVELING IN GROUPS AND
REMAINING VIGILANT HAS PEOPLE
HERE ON EDGE.
>> SO CONFUSING BECAUSE IT WAS A
TARGETED ATTACK THAT NOW SUGGEST
IF PEOPLE SHOULD BE IN FEAR FOR
THEIR LIFE THAT THIS GUY MAY
ATTACK AGA